hello and welcome to this video playing
get him get on this Emil's this is all
from Amador let's see what he does Kings
Indian by transposition maybe or yep
let's see how we place this having an
early night a section and this is
something that I have not yet studied
ready in my Petrosian system planned
repertoire I know that this exists but I
don't know the details but should be 394
and then I think you take who I can
think i could see ya look it up in the
book somewhere here but I don't do that
of course so night h5
[Music]
yeah g3 is offered the right reaction
but here I'm not sure here's a five and
then i th floor maybe that is indeed
looking a little bit shaky so maybe
without a single second is it the step
so clearly bad but see what is why is
that working for luck right f4 or and
okay maybe this works by some miracle
stuff like this should take 96 and all
the Sun here's some compensation we
might have some compensation but ok I
mean I can just do that let's play this
and then work out the details so 96 if I
take one in five he might play g5 and
very likely will play geez hon so I'm
taking this
and now we are look at six probably know
is ready to give up the exchange but if
i just take here and then take a high
for this video let's do that
you
94 doesn't work it's close close though
I gotta check the check is even more
convincing and so look at three I mean
Bishop takes I can play loop tags OOP
takes Queen takes Queen take the 597
this is this trick now the other thing i
can do i can just drop back to h whoa
and keep everything covered is easier
now look here stopping the queen and
attending good cheer for in some
situations
and so I'm not spoiling this would be a
kind of frustrating I also threaten
ethics here so we stopping this I can
check now here also yeah this is not so
bad king after 896 is pretty good and he
cannot go to this side and so can't take
it take this one how to do that I wonder
if I should just play Queenie 20 trade
Queens but only not the night year is
night should come to a point we 6 is
possible and if it takes it the position
opens up I'm an exchange and two pawns
up so the main danger is some some
swindle here 91 with that that's not a
big deal I really don't mind that
okay so 96 on I was thinking Queenie to
it was my original idea time warning
system make it theatrum wherever we
looked at 96 isn't a fork fortunately I
was really thinking it's a fork
when i get a five
[Music]
follows a bit simpler check
black resign well okay tough I'm even
though it was on winning position most
of the game it's still tricky i mean
this guy is european champion so i want
to find the old trick the position how
the opening was just too bad and five
really looked unplayable and he played
it like in two seconds well this is more
more or less than done but you have to
yes you have to be a precise we are here
taking this is probably not that clear
after the deposition looks extremely
messy to climb might be better for white
which it looks messy and this much much
this was much easier just keep
everything every piece with clay and any
blunder big change on top can I mean I
think the chat reasonably clean and
neither force in the engines move I mean
that I didn't expect but it makes
perfect sense as I have to trade now is
only active read active p so on chapter
the this I'm giving stuff back but I can
it control now over this position the
two pawns are just just too much yeah
after the a pork or plundered yes no
breakthrough itim something like this i
can i can play 93 a thought even this is
possible TX and I hide on a one
too much material okay yeah so at the
end i managed to evolve on it okay
thanks for watching